et passez plafond autorisé
j'utilise cette carte uniquement pour le
café et les sens la planète samedi
absolument rien je suis dans le colorado
les plages sont rares elle est où la
bouteille deux soeurs se sont dits golo
paterson
on ne vous a pas vu au tribunal ont
fleuri jamais mis les pieds en floride
demandé une photo c'est qui celle là la
femme qui a usurpé votre identité en
profitant du fait que vous portez un
prénom féminin c'est mixte en fait ça
fait très fine j'en reviens pas d'avoir
tranché tomates
non vous aider la cua ces gros noms il
faudrait que j'ai devant moi ici pour
qu'on avance sur votre dossier c'est la
folie n'est pas un chasseur de primes
c'est notre seule option regardant dire
un hobbit je vais traquer ben il bouffe
je te tiens soit on passe en force
soit on fait ça en douceur je crois que
je vais prendre la douceur douceur on
passe à iéna douceur monture on va
denver tu vas adorer la bahia personne
qui veut ta pauvre peut tenir toute la
journée samedi matin au nom il prouva
que les gens ne peut pas lâcher cette
femme des yeux c'est au delà de tout
si on était un peu de musique
bien